No, no, no.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in
the chapters regarding
and we have arrived at the final part of
and its rulings and that is the
invalidators or the nullifiers
of those things which nullify which
compromise.
Yesterday we discussed the narration of
and that narration of
regarding the two companions that went
out and made prayed and then found
water afterwards or were able to access
water afterwards. And there various
approaches to that.
The author says
here the author says something that is
very interesting
and that is
a response to a common opinion in some
of the med
regarding a person who has water, has
access to water but partially cannot use
it. What does that mean? Partially
cannot use it. So let's say a person has
a cast on or a person has a part of his
body that is
ill or or hurt and he cannot put
water on it. Well, he can use water on
the rest of his body, just not that
part.
So, the scholars approach this in two
different ways.
One group, they say
the person can only partially use water.
So, he finds himself in a middle ground
between water and
he partially needs to and he partially
needs water.
So he uses water with that which he can
and then he makes for that which he
cannot
let's say a person had a cast on his arm
right cannot wash the arm he would make
wool for everything except for that arm
and then he would make
that's one opinion
however this is the weaker opinion why
because we do not have an instance
in the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
nor do we have an instance in the
companions doings in which they used
both and water together. This never
happened. When we look at the way that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala speaks about
it, he speaks about it as
as an alternative and a holistic
alternative, not a partial alternative.
So he says
they are opposites. A person is never in
between. They're either they have water
or they don't. If they have water, then
tayyum doesn't apply. If they do not,
then water doesn't apply. That is the
only way water and are spoken about in
the Quran. So, we understand that they
are not to be used together. This is
very clear.
Another
opinion amongst the scholars and this
is the correct opinion and that is
that a person
fulfills as the prophet himself said
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gives us a
general ruling. He says no soul shall be
burdened with an obligation that it is
unable to fulfill. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam tells us whatever I
command you to do of it as much as you
can. As much as you can. So if a person
has a cast on his arm, how much of wudoo
is as much as he can. He does woo except
for the part that's covered. That's as
much as he can. Correct. Therefore, the
person would not use in this instance.
The person would merely make wudul
and skip the part that they cannot make
wudoo with
as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
instructed generally in these verses
that we've just shared. Now, we have one
more part to that equation.
Do we completely leave off the cast
entirely?
Because
do of it as much as you can. I can't
wash it, but I can perhaps wipe over it.
So, should I wipe over it? Again, this
is two opinions amongst the scholars.
The majority of the scholars say you
would wipe over the part that you cannot
wash and you wash the rest. Others say
no, you don't have to wipe anything
because wiping is a separate type of
worship. You have not been commanded to
wipe over your feet or your arms. You've
been commanded to wash. If you're unable
to wash, then nothing applies.
The majority of the scholars are of the
opinion that a person would wash what he
can and wipe over whatever he cannot and
that is what he is able to do. The
author here takes the third opinion and
that is that whatever you can wash you
wash whatever you cannot you skip and
that is a valid opinion and a strong
opinion especially amongst the hadith
but their is very u very different
approach their hermeneutics to
understanding is very different
especially of
so the point is is that if a person
let's go back. Take it back to the
beginning so that nobody's unclear.
Let's say a person has a cast, right?
Person has a cast.
Now
they are unable to wash it. So what do
they do? Well, they make wool and they
wipe over whatever they cannot wash. And
where do we get this from? Well, when a
person has the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam wiped over his turban, correct?
And making woo. As a matter of fact, why
do we wipe over our hair? When we wipe
over our hair, unless we're bald, you're
wiping over your hair. You're not wiping
over your head, right? Because Allah
commands,
but you wipe over your
hair.
And you're not really wiping over your
head directly. That's because you have
something that is covering your head.
Therefore, you wipe over that person
wipes over their footwear when they're
wearing it. So, it has an an origin in
the Quran and Sunnah. This is why this
is the stronger opinion and the opinion
of the majority. So, a person makes woo,
wipes over the part that they cannot
wash. They wash everything else and
there is no
is a substitute for water not
a not to be coupled with water. They're
never used together. Right?
which we've mentioned.
[Silence]
men.
The final part of this is
the author mentions here
one final thing and that is making
using a wall. Because when we look
back at the wording,
a is what settles on a horizontal
surface really. So what about a vertical
surface? And honestly, this is probably
one of the amendments that the author
made in his later prints of this book
because this belongs at the beginning of
the chapter and it's clear that he kind
of tacked it on here at the end. He
says,
[Silence]
Muslim. So he notes a narration here on
the authority of Ib Abbass that tells
us of a time when the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam made to after
off of a wall. Now what about if the
I'm not going to tell you the answer.
I'm going to see where we've gotten
here. What about if the wall is painted?
Let's say it's painted with an oilbased
paint.
Can you make tyum off of the wall or
does the wall have to be made out of
clay or made out of something that is,
you know, dusty? What's the answer?
[Arabic recitation]
you said yes. Is there a difference of
opinion?
The answer is yes, you can. Because as
we mentioned in detail before,
anything that settles is called site.
Unless there is some super special
painted wall
that specifically is designed
to be so microscopically
slick that even dust cannot settle upon
it. in the under those circumstances by
all means right however until this wall
exists and until this paint exists of
course and I ask you this because it
actually is a difference of opinion
amongst the scholars however it doesn't
have to be dirt it has to be we
discussed that in detail
Subhanahua.